>> Tucker: JUST A FEW MONTHS
AGO BIG TECH BLACKLISTED ELLA
JONES FROM EVERY MAJOR TECH
PLATFORM ALL AT ONCE.
NO ONE REALLY SAID ANYTHING
ABOUT IT BECAUSE ELLA JONES, IT
WILL, WE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO LIKE
HIM.
I THINK IT'S OKAY THAT HE'S
DEFLECT FORMED.
OF COURSE THE TECH OLIGARCHS
WERE EMBOLDENED.
IF THEY COULD SILENCE ONE
PERSON, WHY NOT SILENCE MORE?
OF COURSE, NOW THEY ARE.
JESSE KELLY IS A TWO-TIME
CONGRESSIONAL CANDIDATE, HOSTS A
RADIO SHOW IN HOUSTON.
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO HE CAME ON
THE SHOW AND PREDICTED THAT
TWITTER WOULD EVENTUALLY CENSOR
HIM.
>> YOU WROTE THIS PIECE THAT I
THOUGHT WAS REALLY COMPELLING
ABOUT ALEX JONES AND YOU SAID I
DON'T AGREE WITH ALEX JONES'
VIEWS, BUT THAT'S NOT THE POINT,
THE POINT, AS YOU ARTICULATED
WAS, IF YOU CAN SILENCE THIS GUY
BECAUSE YOU DON'T LIKE WHAT HE
SAYS, WHY CAN'T ASSAILANTS YOU
OR ME?
>> THAT IS THE POINT, AND THEY
ARE COMING FOR YOU AND ME NEXT.
>> Tucker: KELLY TURNED OUT TO
BE RIGHT.
JUST THIS PAST SUNDAY,
YESTERDAY, TWITTER SHUT DOWN HIS
ACCOUNT AND THEY DID NOT EXPLAIN
WHY.
TONIGHT WE ARE TRYING TO FIND
OUT WHAT HAPPENED.
JESSE KELLY JOINS US LIVE.
YOU KNEW THIS WAS COMING, YOU
PRESCIENTLY PREDICTED IT.
WHY DID TWITTER TAKE YOU OFF ITS
PLATFORM?
>> NOBODY KNOWS.
TWITTER KICKED ME OFF THE
PLATFORM BECAUSE I WAS A
MAINSTREAM VOICE ON THE RIGHT
THAT SPOKE THE TRUTH.
THAT'S ALL ANYBODY KNOWS.
THEY'VE GIVEN ME NO EXPLANATION
AS THEY TOLD CONGRESS THEY WOULD
GIVE EXPLANATION.
ALL THEY SENT WAS AN EMAIL THAT
SAYS YOU ARE PERMANENTLY BANNED
AND YOU CAN'T REPEAT IT FOR
REPEATED RULES VIOLATIONS.
I DON'T VIOLATE THE RULES.
I DON'T HARASS PEOPLE ON THERE,
I DON'T DO ANY OF THOSE UGLY
THINGS THAT SOME PEOPLE DO.
TWITTER WAS GOING TO BECOME WHAT
THEY ARE.
ALL OF A SUDDEN MY ACCOUNT
VANISHED LIKE A HILLARY CLINTON
EMAIL.
>> Tucker: DID YOU CALL THEM?
LET ME JUST SAY IF YOU ARE IN
YOUR BUSINESS OR MY BUSINESS,
THAT'S NOT A SMALL THING.
THAT'S ONE OF THE WAYS YOU
COMMUNICATE WITH YOUR LISTENERS,
ONE OF THE WAYS YOU DISSEMINATE
YOUR IDEAS, THE MAIN WHAT YOU
DO.
IF YOU DO CALL TWITTER TO FIND
OUT, DID YOU HAVE ANY CONTACT AT
ALL?
>> NO NUMBER AT ALL, THEY
COMPLETELY BANISHED ME, SO I'M
NOT EVEN ABLE TO LOGIN AND EMAIL
TWITTER SUPPORT.
A FRIEND OF MINE SENT ME A
COUPLE EMAIL ADDRESSES FOR
PEOPLE THAT SUPPOSEDLY WORK AT
TWITTER BUT I'M SURE THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO ANSWER ANY OF THOSE.
THEY DID EXACTLY WHAT I SAID
THEY WOULD DO.
THEY CAME FOR ALEX JONES FIRST
BECAUSE HE'S A NUT JOB AND THEY
WANTED TO SEE HOW THE RATE WOULD
REACT.
THEY GOT HIM AND I KNEW THEY
WERE COMING FOR ME.
IF THEY WILL COME FOR YOU TOO.
>> Tucker: SO WHEN THEY DID
COME FOR ALEX JONES THE IDEA WAS
YOU CAN HAVE HIM BECAUSE HE'S
EMBARRASSING AND NO ONE REALLY
SAID ANYTHING ABOUT IT, IN MY
OPINION A VERY COWARDLY AND
STUPID WAY.
DO YOU THINK IF CONSERVATIVES
ARE NOT EVEN CONSERVATIVES,
PEOPLE WHO CONSENT FROM THE
CONVENTIONAL VIEW OF EVERYTHING
WE ARE NOW REQUIRED TO BELIEVE
AT GUNPOINT, IF THE REST OF US
START TO COMPLAIN DO THINK WE
CAN PUSH BACK AGAINST CENSORSHI
CENSORSHIP?
>> I THINK WE CAN AND I THINK
THAT'S WHERE THE REAL POWER IS.
IT'S NOT A BIG DEAL THAT I GOT
KICKED OFF TWITTER.
IT HURTS TWITTER WORSE THAN THEY
HURT ME BECAUSE THEY FINALLY
KICKED OFF SOMEBODY WHO WOKE
EVERYBODY THE WRITE UP.
PEOPLE ARE NOW STARTING TO
REALIZE WHAT TWITTER HAS BECOME.
IT'S A BLANK PIECE OF PAPER THAT
SOMEHOW WOKE UP ONE DAY I
DECIDED THEY WERE THE ARTIST,
THEY WERE IN CONTROL OF WHAT YOU
PUT ON THAT PIECE OF PAPER AND
THAT'S NOT WHERE THEIR POWER
LIES.
SO IF THEY CONTINUE ALONG THIS
PATH IT'S GOING TO BE NOTHING
BUT TWO FEMINISTS SCREAMING AT
EACH OTHER BECAUSE ONE OF THEM
ACCIDENTALLY FOUND A BOYFRIEND.
>> Tucker: AM I
MISUNDERSTANDING THIS OR DO THE
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS HAVE A
CONGRESSIONAL EXEMPTION THAT
ALLOWS THEM NOT TO BE HELD
LEGALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR THINGS
THAT ARE SET ON THEIR PLATFORM,
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY ARE NOT
MEDIA COMPANIES AND IT CAN'T BE
SUED AS MEDIA COMPANIES CAN BE
SUED?
BUT NOW THEY ARE ACTING LIKE
MEDIA COMPANIES, HOW DOES THAT
WORK?
>> HOW IT WORKS AS THEY HAVE THE
BEST OF BOTH WORLDS.
YOU HAVE IT EXACTLY RIGHT, THEY
ARE TREATED LIKE MEDIA
PLATFORMS, MEANING THEY ARE JUST
AN OPEN SITE WHERE PEOPLE CAN
POST WHAT THEY WANT AS LONG AS
THEY ARE NOT INCITING VIOLENCE,
ONLY THEY ARE ACTING LIKE THINK
PROGRESS, THEY ARE ACTING LIKE
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" BECAUSE
THESE RADICAL VOICES ON THE LEFT
NEVER GET CENSORED, EVEN
FARRAKHAN, THAT COMPLETE SCUMBAG
THAT HAS A SUITE STILL UP